it's the fourth anniversary of pubg
mobile the greatest of all battle
royales and we're going to celebrate
with a journey through some of the
coolest stuff the original battle royale
on mobile has to offer from guns to our
favorite maps and drop spots we're gonna
take a look at our top four faves in
four different categories to celebrate
pubg mobile's fourth birthday
pubg mobile is all about the guns and
you have a wide range of options
available to you from sniper rifles to
smgs it's a highly debated topic but
here are choices for the four best guns
in the game the m416 is the best
all-around gun in the game whether
you're a marksman or somebody who just
likes to spray bullets across the
battleground
when you absolutely positively need to
take someone down in one shot the awm
sniper rifle is the only way to go the
ump 45 is our favorite smg because it's
got that little bit of extra range that
makes it more than just a short range
bullet sprayer it's kind of a middle
range bullets prayer for those wild
short range battles nothing beats the
dbs shotgun it can fire 14 bullets
before you need to reload
every pubg map is awesome but some are
more awesome than others you can't go
wrong with arangell the original map
expansive and complete with some
memorable hot spots including pachinky
and school
then we have the oh so lovely desert
themed miramar which is always a nice
change of pace just remember to duck
because it's a sniper's paradise and
always great for some mountainside
battles pubg mobile's exclusive map
livik is the smallest map in the game
which is perfect for when you don't have
time to grind out a chicken dinner on
arangel
finally you have the kindy where you can
battle it out in a winter wonderland
snowmobiles got em snow dirt bike things
also got em pubg mobile's expansive maps
offer so many great landing spots but
here are the four that we just cannot
stop going back to we like dropping at
school when we play on erengel because
it usually gets to just the right amount
of tilted in there class is in session
when dropping into miramar the gorgeous
villa hacienda del patron is always
heated but it's also got the best loot
which is exactly what you'd expect from
a giant mansion in the middle of a
desert in the lush sanhok mat mognai is
usually pretty quiet but it's always
worth the visit just look at all those
palm trees
finally the hot springs on livik may not
have the best loot but a healing bath
there will save your life if you're out
of healing items or if you just want to
relieve a little in-game stress
there are plenty of slick cars you can
get in pubg mobile and they're all good
choices for getting around but some
choices are more good than others
the koenigsegg jesco might be the
slickest of the bunch show up to the
fight early in a swedish supercar during
the tesla collaboration you could build
yourself a self-driving model y shooting
from the window of a self-driving car is
the battle royale move of the future
daryl's motorcycle from the walking dead
may not look like much from far away but
this rusty beast from the apocalypse has
so much character and in the shop and
loot boxes right now you can grab the
perfect off-road wasteland vehicle the
past glory buggy looks like something
right out of mad max as you can see the
first four years of pub g mobile have
given us an extraordinary amount of cool
stuff and since pubg mobile is one of
the biggest games in the world it's a
safe bet that the next four will be even
more amazing
you